city so this is what happens I don't
know if you know about this our public
said where each people know this clip is
a reputation around the country grabbing
the best audiences in the country so
people like this just to play for you
guys the only reason he's here is
because you have a reputation for being
so good he's coming here to play my club
so don't ruin this for me how's Kim
[Music]
hello guys good to be here my name is
Hans Kim and I have a lot of confidence
right now
that's probably why he respect me so
much I think confidence is important
because as we all know the loudest
voices are the most correct a equals
mc-squared was famously shouted by
eyesight
I think all this is great cuz without
confidence stupid people would have no
idea who to pay attention to let me just
running around all over the place Who am
I why am I here okay that guy's making
strong noises that's all that guy and
those are called elections the system is
broken man so I I don't think capitalism
is too bad I mean it's fine if you want
to do it but don't make everyone play
your stupid game I like fortnight I
don't make a grandma play and take away
our house if she loses think about it I
have a big supporter of universal basic
income I think if everyone got $1,000
every month you guys would be a lot more
bearable to be around there's another
buck stop peeing on me I I don't
understand these CEOs or like how am I
supposed to motivate my
if I can't throw them with homelessness
I mean if I want people to work on my
company I have a have to have a company
that people want to work for what
whatever happen to depriving them of
health care till I work for us
oh my god I'm so I'm so uh so smart I I
think I think I'm pretty cool I'm not
that into anime but anyone who is
sexually attracted to me is pretty into
anime pretty into anime now I'm on day
it's like oh I'm Korean I don't know
what the [ __ ] they're saying yeah I like
to eat General Tso's chicken and my
friends my Asian friends are like
honza's and General Tso's chicken a
shitty Americanized version of something
authentically Asian and I'm like yeah
but so am i my favorite movie is rush
hour three stupid I love you know living
in New York City
ooh that's pretty cool I hate when
homeless people beg for change on the
subway so what I usually do is I switch
cars that way I can set me up say no to
them over and over again to their face
sometimes I'll switch two cars in front
of them and do their whole life before
they get there really [ __ ] their [ __ ] up
the hard this time don't go with your
scripts I want to hear what you really
have to say I like how in New York City
they have extra security on 9/11 as if
it's the date that's the problem and not
our foreign policy
like a lipid Daisy there's no temper
these terrorists get a little kooky oh
my god maybe something about this date I
thought I do you have a terrace flipping
through the calendar like oh look 9/11
is coming up we should do something nice
I I'm not a communist but I do support
any policies that Republicans consider
communism which is whenever two or more
people gathered to do something nice I
find it funny when Americans will be
like communism never works as if they
didn't spend billions of dollars and
kill millions of people to make sure it
wouldn't work
remember Vietnam guys are pretty anxious
about it now working communism never
works because whatever people control
the means of production their
democratically elected leaders
mysteriously died and a small replica
new boys finds automatic weapons somehow
look they hated themselves they look
stupid then so I live in a van if you
couldn't tell you know think outside the
box
communism and apartment wise every way I
live in a van the reason why I live in a
van PB is so that I could pursue comedy
full-time so if you didn't think I was
funny like she did I'm sorry I'm trying
really hard I'm at a peak performance
right now I know there's someone in the
back like yeah that was funny but not
living your van funny gonna read that
joke in an apartment
all right oh thank you before I start
working with him he was not even easy